y
[Música]
moscú quiere ir más allá del donbass
según eeuu los rusos pretenden tomar
todas las zonas ucranianas que conectan
hasta moldavia además hubo nuevos
bombardeos en odessa y al menos una
persona falleció este es un intento por
frenar la entrada de alimentos y armas
conectaremos con ucrania
'francia conmemoró el día nacional de
las memorias de la esclavitud y de su
abolición tendremos reportes sobre como
la historia se cuenta de manera
diferente en las escuelas de martinica y
de la ciudad francesa de nyon
no culpable se declaró el expresidente
de honduras juan orlando hernández el
antiguo mandatario negó ante un tribunal
de manhattan en eeuu los tres cargos que
se le imputan por tráfico de cocaína
posesión de armas pesadas y conspiración
para la posición del armamento
analizaremos en minutos
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda varia clara calle empecemos
hablando de la guerra en ucrania y es
que inteligencia de eeuu afirma que el
presidente vladimir putin se estaría
preparando para un conflicto prolongado
la directora del organismo a bill gates
estuvo ante el senado estadounidense que
moscú quiere controlar territorio más
allá de la región separatista del
donbass y que putin podría incluso
ordenar una ley marcial en rusia su
información es que las tropas de moscú
tienen la intención de ganar territorio
a lo largo de la costa del mar negro
hasta llegar a moldavia una de esas
zonas claves es la ciudad portuaria de
odessa que hoy fue bombardeada con tres
misiles hipersónicos en un hecho que
dejó al menos un muerto y cinco heridos
ucrania afirma que moscú quiere cortar
el puerto de entrada de armas
occidentales y la salida clave de granos
de exportación
la batalla por el control de la ruta que
conduce hacia lizzie lizzie guns en el
este de ucrania es estratégica en la
lucha por la provincia de lugansk donde
los enfrentamientos se han intensificado
en los últimos días si esta vía cae
varias poblaciones que se encuentran en
medio del fuego cruzado quedarán
aisladas nuestros enviados especiales
catalina gómez ángel y mikel konaté
llegaron hasta allí y prepararon este
informe sobre la situación que
encontraron
esta carretera es el nuevo gran objetivo
de las fuerzas rusas que buscan cortar
el acceso a la provincia de lugares en
el este del país
de lograr su objetivo ciudades como lis
y chang's quedarán aisladas y muy cerca
de quedar bajo el control del gobierno
de moscú
el cruce de fuego y los bombardeos hacen
que irse a una misión marcada por el
peligro
este es el caso de natacha alexander y
hiena que esperan la llegada de buses
humanitarios para ser evacuados
la noche fue el límite y atacaron este
lugar ayer nuestras casas fueron
destruidas perdimos todo
da mucho miedo
empezaron a bombardear no es tan duro
imagínense un proyectil volando por
encima de mi cabeza y explotar en frente
de mí es un milagro que logramos escapar
de ese lugar después de horas de espera
han entendido que los ataques impiden
que los vehículos lleguen a su rescate
antonina aprovecha que los ataques han
mermado y ha salido a dar un paseo
tenemos muchos problemas con el agua
potable vamos al pozo y la sacamos de
allí
cada uno tiene sus razones para quedarse
a pesar de los peligros como misiles
como este que ha quedado sin explotar
en esta área se libró una de las
batallas más duras por el dominio del
este del país la ciudad ha quedado
atrapada en el cruce de fuego de las
fuerzas rusas ucranianas que la
defienden desde los alrededores
la vida para las pocas personas que se
han quedado indecisión es un básicamente
un infierno hay bombardeos hay
artillería que cae en las calles están
completamente solas nos dicen que no hay
agua tampoco hay electricidad no hay
conexión a internet no hay líneas
telefónicas y ellos nos dicen que
solamente cuando bajan un poco los
ataques salen a la calle compran su
comida y vuelven a sus casas a los
refugios subterráneos
la situación económica también impide
que muchos tomen la decisión de
marcharse como ara que venden las
verduras y huevos que producen su jardín
horrible la situación es horrible
bombardean todos los días incluso lo
hicieron el 9 de mayo ferrán el futuro
de la ciudad y los habitantes que
permanecen depende de la lucha que se
libra en esta carretera donde hasta
bailar bandera ucraniana sigue ondeando
cada 10 de mayo francia conmemora el día
nacional del recuerdo del tráfico de
personas esclavizadas la esclavitud y su
abolición hoy el presidente de manuel
presidió la ceremonia en el jardín de
luxemburgo de parís la capital aunque la
historia está oficialmente incorporada
en los planes de estudio desde 2001 no
siempre se diseña de la misma manera en
otros territorios de ultramar la
historia la tienen nuestros colegas de
france télévision
a la derecha el instituto jackman de
rivia kilos en la isla territorial
francesa de martinica a la izquierda en
institutos anti exúpery en la comunidad
en yoga en la francia continental dos
aulas y dos enfoques distintos de la
educación sobre la esclavitud es los
esclavizados venían de áfrica entre 300
y 400 eran encadenados en el casco del
barco donde hacía calor show un pedazo
de historia oscuro y esencial que debe
ser enseñado y discutido con las
próximas generaciones para no olvidar
nunca lo que sufrieron los hombres y
mujeres esclavizados en francia cuando
hacemos nuestra vida cotidiana olvidamos
que la esclavitud existió aquí en
martinica y los alumnos repasan antes de
un examen poniendo a prueba sus
conocimientos de las condiciones en que
los esclavizados fueron llevados a las
antillas desde áfrica
los esclavizados serán traídos en la
carga del barco no tenían mucho espacio
spas no les alimentaban mucho y eran
tratados como bestias como animales al
otro lado del atlántico los alumnos de
3º del instituto sanger supreme y en el
continente francés discuten el tema de
la esclavitud a través de lo que han
aprendido de la radio las obras de
teatro y los poemas un día la historia
los recordará puede ser a través de
libros ilustrados con justicia y respeto
después de tanto dolor escribe es la
esclavitud es un periodo que nunca
debemos olvidar porque todavía existe y
si existe you is la historia es la
memoria y también es lo que construye
nuestra sociedad si es una mente abierta
nos impide cerrarnos de ir hacia los
extremos yo les digo a mis alumnos que
debemos estar abiertos de intentar
comprender el pasado para ver el
presente de otra manera uno pesó la
esclavitud colonial y el tráfico de
esclavizados pasaron a formar parte de
los planes de estudios nacionales y se
integraron en los libros de texto cuando
se adoptó la ley atómica el 10 de mayo
de 2001
pasamos a américa latina' el
expresidente hondureño juan orlando
hernández se declaró no culpable de
narcotráfico ante un tribunal federal de
manhattan negó haber recibido millones
de dólares a cambio de no arrestar a
narcotraficantes mientras gobernaba
honduras los fiscales estadounidenses le
imputaron tres cargos mientras los
abogados de hernández denuncian que no
lo tratan como a un ex mandatario sino
como a un prisionero de guerra vamos a
san pedro sula donde está sergio vélez
politólogo hondureño señor vélez
bienvenido a france 24 explíquenos qué
podría pasar en el caso de juan orlando
hernández y qué procedimientos vendrán
buenas noches maría clara muchísimas
gracias realmente tenemos que ser claros
en este sentido las autoridades verdad
partiendo del fiscal general el señor
garland
presentaron una acusación como el
gobierno de los eeuu o sea estamos
hablando de que los pesos pesados están
detrás de una investigación que lleva
años en la cual ellos de acuerdo a su
investigación tienen como demostrar que
a través de todas estas entidades
organizaciones de narcotráfico
infiltraron al gobierno de honduras
verdad y pues obviamente de la mano de
lo que es el presidente juan orlando
hernández pudieron encontrar una
colaboración para hacer de este pues un
aliado para poder
transportar enormes cantidades de droga
hablando de 500 toneladas verdad que fue
una situación que también manifestó el
fiscal de distrito damian williams y por
lo cual él y ahora está enfrentando
duros cargos en este país del norte y si
los pesos pesados de la justicia
estadounidense están detrás de este caso
como usted lo dice porque hernández se
declara no culpable en vez de buscar un
acuerdo
obviamente tenemos que entender algo
miramar y aclara si él llegara a una
condición de aceptar algún tipo de
situación que correspondiera a una
culpabilidad estaría incluso teniendo
que enfrentar la situación de que se
pueda acusar a su esposa verdad como
cómplice acusar a todos engranaje
político dentro de la gobernanza de ocho
años entonces aquí hay mucha implicación
a él se le está mostrando como gran capo
y mira y esto es una estructura criminal
que no es de una persona no podemos
suponer que con orlando hernández movió
500 toneladas pero imagínate la
estructura o sea las acusaciones y lo
que viene después de esto es
requerimiento de miles de personas
verdad que tuvieron involucramiento y
podemos decir uno de ellos fue
extraditado como una persona que se
acusa de haber colaborado con hernández
verdad y me refiero al ex general de
policía verdad comido como el tigre
ponía el señor juan carlos ponía hoy fue
extraditado con ese mismo propósito
usted habla del hermano del exmandatario
tory hernández y lo menciona en la
estructura que tanto le puede jugar esto
en contra al expresidente bueno
realmente creo que el juez kevin castel
tuvo una expresión muy visceral en lo
que fue la lectura de la sentencia de
tony hernández al manifestar que ya en
ese momento el nombre de juan orlando
hernández ya no era co conspirador 4 no
eras ese 4 sino que los puso con nombre
y apellido y le dice usted junto a su
hermano el presidente juan orlando
hernández
hicieron para poder traer aquí demasiada
droga y eso daño a la gente en eeuu y
eso es por lo cual usted tiene que pagar
entonces yo creo que esta situación hay
una situación que tony hernández no pudo
actuar en un país donde nunca tuvo ni
una esquela de tráfico sin haber tenido
la protección de su hermano que
recordemos que nunca es un presidente es
la persona más informada y con mayor
inteligencia y que él no lo supiera nos
deja mucho que desear sergio vélez
gracias por estar en france 24
graciasmaria clara un placer azul y el
fiscal paraguayo marcelo pecci
reconocido por su trabajo en la lucha
contra el crimen fue asesinado en la
isla colombiana de barú cerca de
cartagena él estaba celebrando su luna
de miel con su esposa la periodista
claudia aguilera todavía no se conocen
las causas pero la fiscalía y la policía
colombiana ya iniciaron una
investigación a la que se sumaron los
paraguayos y los estadounidenses
el fiscal marcelo pecci fue asesinado en
la isla colombiana de barú cercana a la
turística ciudad de cartagena de indias
estaba encargado de investigar casos de
narcotráfico lavado de dinero y crimen
organizado en su país seguirá en la
lucha contra el crimen organizado en el
latina esto es muy doloroso muy duro he
conversado con el presidente iván duque
por teléfono que se comprometió conmigo
para darnos todo nuestro apoyo para
resolver el caso para buscar a los
responsables
también he conversado con el gobierno
americano con respecto a eso quienes
también a través de colombia van a
apoyar casos como el del futbolista
brasileño ronaldinho quien en 2020
intentó entrar en paraguay con un
pasaporte falso el del asesinato de la
hija de un gobernador regional le dieron
reconocimiento a nivel nacional e
internacional al fiscal de 45 años que
además investigaba el asesinato de dos
personas durante un festival paraguayo
mientras tocaba un grupo musical
colombiano conocido como el binomio de
euro
ya tenemos informaciones que están
siendo recolectadas en los actos
urgentes y que son de carácter reservado
que nos ayudarán a identificar a los
responsables de este lamentable hecho
una delegación de la policía paraguaya
formará parte del equipo de
investigación en colombia en el que
también participarán funcionarios de
eeuu
en filipinas hubo protestas luego de que
se conoció que ferdinand marcos juniors
lidera el conteo preliminar con el 98
por ciento de los votos elegibles ya
contados veamos
manifestantes furiosos salieron a las
calles de manila cuando los resultados
de las elecciones revelaron la victoria
no oficial de ferdinand marcos júnior
que se convertirá en el próximo
presidente de filipinas y decide la
gente aquí no lo acepta no creo que
nunca lo acepten están aquí para
expresar un profundo sentimiento de
indignación por el sistema político de
filipinas que ha permitido que el
heredero del dictador marcos vuelva al
poder como presidente marcos
apodado bombón marcos juniors aplastó a
su rival en y robredo para convertirse
en el primer candidato presidencial en
la historia reciente del país en ganar
con una mayoría absoluta pero los
críticos dicen que su campaña estuvo
marcada por el blanqueo de la notoria
dinastía de su familia y muchos temen
que su liderazgo refleje la brutal y
corrupta dictadura de su padre las
peticiones para descalificar al
candidato de 64 años fueron desestimadas
por el organismo electoral filipino
y estoy muy asustada y muy muy
decepcionado de que esto esté ocurriendo
en mi país ahora mismo nunca en mi vida
pensé que viviría otra presidencia de
marcos esto es muy deprimente
sinceramente
por su parte marcos juniors ha prometido
trabajar para el pueblo y ha pedido que
se le juzgue por su presidencia y no por
el pasado de su familia su compañera de
fórmula es sara duterte hija del
presidente saliente rodrigo duterte
quien a pesar de su gobierno autoritario
conserva un amplio apoyo el ganador de
los comicios tomará posesión del cargo a
finales de junio para un mandato único
de seis años
espero en france 24
[Música]